so
[Music]
all over this broad land of ours
a bit of war is being fought against
tuberculosis
able warriors armed with modern weapons
around the firing line how goes the
battle
come with me on a journey and let's see
what is being done
first to washington to get a few facts
in this building is the census bureau
where uncle sam keeps his health record
books
there is a card here for each of us
telling when we were born when married
what we die of and many other facts
ingenious machines sought these cards so
that statistics may be compiled from
them
imagine all the people in the united
states divided into groups of one
hundred thousand each here is one such
group
this christian iron represents 50 deaths
from tuberculosis
in 1910 there were about 150 deaths from
tuberculosis for each 100 000 persons
we need three irons in this role ten
years later there were one hundred
deaths per hundred thousand persons two
words
and
in 1935 about 50 only one earned
death rate cut to one third of what it
was 25 years ago what a retreat
[Applause]
[Music]
next we visit new york city
where so much of the nation's business
is transacted
in
new york the headquarters of the
national tuberculosis association
its network of state county and city
associations covers the country
including our territories and
possessions
the whole enterprise is financed by the
sale of tuberculosis christmas seals
which you buy each year
renowned artists create a new design for
the seal each year
here is rockwell kent at work on one
the local tuberculosis associations send
them out to you and me
in some places the scouts or other
organizations lend a hand
every seal carries a message of hope and
cheer
with the money these associations keep
up the fight through education of the
people by the printed word
pamphlets
posters
the newspaper exhibits radio education
of the people and through them of the
state is the first and greatest need in
the prevention of tuberculosis
these were the words of edward
livingston trudeau our first president
when in 1905 he charted the course of
the national tuberculosis association
let's go next to saranac lake and the
beautiful adirondacks which dr trudeau
loves so well
here is the brown statue of trudeau
reclining in his chair
a pulse of characteristic of his own
successful struggle against tuberculosis
it was trudeau who introduced the modern
treatment of tuberculosis in this
country
rest fresh air
and good food
nestling in the hills now surrounded by
fine buildings we find the little red
the first cottage built by trudeau in
1884 for the treatment of two young
women
it is served as the inspiration for the
more than 700 sanatoria built since then
[Music]
let's have a look at one of these
sanatoria or tuberculosis hospitals as
they are called today
real hospitals for the tuberculosis and
not merely resting places
here we are in a large southern
sanatorium
this one has beds for 500 patients
altogether there are now 90 000 such
beds available
rest and more rest as trudeau discovered
when he himself took the cure as a young
doctor
yes and good food
nowadays doctors don't stuff patients
with more milk and eggs than they can
digest
just good well-balanced meals enough to
gain weight on
smell those delicious loaves
new ways of resting the lung have been
developed this patient is getting
pneumothorax treatment
air is let into the chest cavity and
that rests the lungs so that it can heal
when the diseased lung is fully healed
it is allowed to expand again
a lifesaver for many
each patient is helped to find his place
in the workaday world when he leaves the
sanatorium
here's a class in typewriting
in this sanatorium as in many others
children of tuberculous parents who
cannot be properly protected otherwise
are cared for in the special department
of the sanatorium
[Music]
finding the cases of tuberculosis is a
very important job
not only the specialist but the family
doctor too
is constantly on the alert knowing that
tuberculosis may disguise itself as some
other disease
doctors in the villages and country
districts too
keep in mind the dangers of unsuspected
disease
even when patients do not complain of
the common symptoms such as cough
tiredness loss of weight or indigestion
the alert doctor thinks of tuberculosis
clinics for the diagnosis of
tuberculosis now exist in every
enterprising community
specialists are in charge and x-ray
services at hand
public health nurses teach the families
of those who have tuberculosis
they see that the doctor's orders are
faithfully carried out they urge all
members of the family to be examined
for tuberculosis though not inherited
runs in families
what about the thousands of people in
out of the way places
let's see how they do it in the bayou
country
[Music]
work in the cane fields under the hot
sun is picturesque but mighty hard labor
these sections are not well equipped
with clinics or x-ray apparatus so
necessary to discover tuberculosis
very well says the health department if
people cannot come to the doctor the
doctor and all he needs will go to the
people
here is an auto trailer expertly
designed which carries complete
equipment for making diagnosis in the
modern manner
a doctor and nurse go with the outfit
advance arrangements are made with the
doctors and local health departments so
that all who should be examined will be
on hand when the trailer comes
here we are arriving on the public
square alongside the courthouse and
ready for business
quietly and efficiently the work is
carried on by skilled workers the family
doctor gets the report of the x-ray
examination of his patient
inside the trailer everything is snug
and ship shape
it looks compact doesn't it but there's
space enough to do the job well
the dressing room is just a corner
screened off by a curtain
the x-ray apparatus is one of the latest
models for a poor x-ray picture may be
worse than none
efficiency and economy make it possible
to give this important service to the
people
snap all over
the plate is removed later we to be
developed in the dark room and in a
moment the next patient will go through
the same steps inside the courthouse or
sometimes a school or church the doctor
makes the rest of the examination gets
the history of the patient and consults
with the local doctor about the patient
then on their way again to the next town
up and down throughout the state this
showed you but one of several such
diagnostic auto trailers now being used
in rural areas
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now we are in a large midwestern
university
we meet the flower of american manhood
in womanhood
how many of them will fall victims to
tuberculosis well if nobody cares at
least six out of each 1 thousand
students before they reach their
thirties
but someone does care
enough to search out the very beginnings
of the disease before there are any
signs or
symptoms all students are given this
simple tuberculin test to show whether
tuberculosis germs have entered the body
all who have tuberculosis germs in their
bodies are x-rayed
one out of four in this university
tuberculosis must be seen before it is
heard say the doctors that's why they
urge all young people to be tested with
tuberculin and to be x-rayed if positive
the x-ray plate is developed in the dark
room
much as you develop your own kodak
pictures in the mysterious amber lighted
closet at home
when the film is dry the shadows are
or interpreted by the doctor
here's the chess picture of a young
athlete the trained eye of the physician
sees the damage already done by
tuberculosis
the fight also goes on in the quiet
research laboratory
scientists are studying the life and
habits of the germ
did you know that the tuberculosis germ
actually breathes eats and reproduces
they are finding out how the germ causes
disease and also how the body defends
itself
someday maybe they'll give us a specific
cure
but don't exalt yet
there is another side to this optimistic
picture
the death rate has gone down true
but seventy thousand tuberculosis
victims still march to their graves each
year and many more are disabled
most of them are young people in that
period of life when it is most
productive and sweet
eager students young parents wage
earners on the upgrade of life
not an old man's disease this but a
bitter foe of youth
here they are the young people we are
concerned about
out of each 100 000 in the age group 15
to 45
66 died last year
there's another source spot on the
optimistic picture
certain racial groups such as negros
mexicans and indians suffer heavy losses
from tuberculosis the death rate among
negroes is three times as high as among
whites not only in the southland but
also in the northern industrial centers
poverty bad housing and a depressed
scale of living seem to be largely
responsible
living cheaply really means living
expensively
how would you like to try to keep warm
this way
buying your firewood at the curb
sixteen sticks for five cents
and when that is gone perhaps on some
cold night
having to pinch pennies for food is
another hardship
rabbits two for a quarter
here's the chart we saw before
showing the decline in the death rate
among whites
each of these strips represents 100 000
negroes
and each earn 50 deaths from
tuberculosis
but notice that the decline has been
just as rapid as that among whites
and in 1935 negro suffered no more
deaths than whites did in 1910
there's a lag but the trend is hopeful
another problem
industrial workers
did you know that tuberculosis is the
particular enemy of the working classes
the men and women on whom rest the
prosperity and welfare of this nation
in this chart each group represents ten
thousand men with a job
here are the professional men here are
the white collar workers
the farmers and foresters
here the skilled workers and finally the
unskilled workers
each urn represents one death from
tuberculosis among these workers
professional men not many deaths among
them
clerks about three times as many
agricultural workers seem to fare pretty
well
skilled workers a little more than
clerks
and unskilled workers
here's our problem
look at the irons
17 out of each 10 000 die of
tuberculosis each year
this time we go west
arizona new mexico colorado and
california for here there is still
another problem
years ago it got noised about that
climate was a magic cure
that era is still believed by many
but out here in the southwest
there are no nobody knows but perhaps 5
000 persons who have tuberculosis
roaming aimlessly about looking for help
some of them come alone
spend their last dollar for railroad
fare and cheap lodging look in vain for
a job and
dying
others bundle up the whole family in the
old car and start out blindly just
hoping to make a new start
they sell them fine work eek out a
miserable existence and when the last
drop of gasoline gives out they become a
burden on some hard press community
little can be done for them for they
have lost their settlement rights
they don't stay long enough in one place
to win the rights of a resident
the children suffer neglect and are
constantly exposed to the danger of
getting tuberculosis from the sick
parents they become shrouded in gloom
and despair whatever becomes of them no
one seems to know precisely
though some excellent studies of this
situation are now underway
this problem is our business not only
because we are our brother's keeper but
also because every such sick wanderer
carries a seize of tuberculosis along
the countryside the wandering
consumptive is of course only part of
the larger problem of migration
which social organizations and
government departments are trying hard
to solve
uh home again
that's part of the journey
but you know that we are still on the
front line
for tuberculosis threatens every
doorstep
rich poor and medium class
and no home is safe
until every home is safe
[Music]
you